it was a refreshing sight in north las
vegas for a few hours
mark stone was not one of the best
players in the world he was not the face
of the golden knights
he was the toy drive volunteer
struggling to fit a four foot bike into
a three foot trunk
this was more rewarding than a power
play the north las vegas police the
chamber of commerce and
presenting sponsor anthem wanted to hold
a drive through christmas giveaway
they took toy donations for several
weeks and then on game day got an assist
from the golden knights
the turnout was massive leaders expected
a few dozen cars to
shuffle through on short notice instead
there were 200
in the first hour it was the ultimate
example of unity
and the best goal scorer in town helped
north las vegas exceed every christmas
goal
imaginable christmas sometimes is
some of the best times of the year but
also some of the hardest times of the
year so
for these kids to come in out here and
the policeman
to help out and give these kids an
opportunity to get some of these gifts
means a lot to our community our goal is
to just
be a blessing to our community and to
build unity
we it's time for us to become more
unified
more than anything for the first time
since october we can actually talk to
hockey players about a hockey season
training camp will begin on january 3rd
for the golden knights
and yes there is one prized piece of
silver on their mind
when i signed here for for eight seasons
[Music]
i was under the understanding that this
organization wanted to win the stanley
cup
and that's why i committed so quickly
for me the only thing left is
to win the stanley cup that's the only
thing that's on on my mind and
i think for the guys who are going to be
competing for
for our team this year that's the only
goal that we have